[Music]
one of the most important lessons I've
learned as a developer is to work
smarter and not harder and one of the
best ways to live by that rule is to use
tools that make you more productive and
simplify your life today we'll look at
seven different tools that I use
personally that you may or may not have
heard of in fact if you're already using
all seven of these tools go ahead and
download the video but otherwise make
sure to LIKE and subscribe and leave a
comment below because I'll be picking
one random comment next week to win this
t-shirt first a little bit about myself
I'm a front-end web developer slash
back-end engineer / ux designer /
entrepreneur / accidental youtuber and
video creator so the list you're about
to see is very much geared towards
developers who are involved at virtually
every point in the product creation
process and full disclosure nobody pays
me a dime to say nice things about these
products they're tools that I use in my
day-to-day work that I generally enjoy
and think will be useful to you let's
get started in no particular order with
bundle phobia this is a web application
that allows you to determine how much an
NPM package will add to your total
bundle size if you're working with a
modern front-end framework you want to
try and keep the bundle size as small as
possible to optimize the initial page
load for new users bundle phobia makes
it very easy to analyze the addition of
a new dependency to your project just
enter the package name and it will tell
you the bundle size the download time
whether or not it's tree shaker Bowl as
well as a bunch of other information for
every single version of that package and
you can even upload your entire package
JSON to see all of your dependencies
ranked by size if you suffer from bundle
phobia like I do this is definitely an
app you have to check out now let's
check out another web app that will help
you design and budget your cloud
infrastructure called cloud craft it's
currently only available for AWS but
even though I mostly use GCP I still
find it useful it provides a very
intuitive drag-and-drop interface that
allows you to connect different cloud
infrastructure services together not
only is this great for planning but it's
also great for budgeting once you have
your infrastructure in place you can go
to the budget tab and it will give you
an estimated breakdown of your total
cost and because all the major clouds
have similar pricing models the actual
results will translate pretty well to
Azure and GCP next up is figma which is
probably the most well known app on this
list but I'm a longtime Adobe
Illustrator user so for me to switch to
figma means it has to offer at least 10
times more value than illustrator and it
actually delivers on that in a variety
of ways first of all figma is a design
tool that allows you to draw graphics
create mock-ups for your apps and while
it provides a desktop app it also
provides a web app that's just as good
and perform it as the desktop version
and it achieves such amazing performance
by using webassembly
it seems kind of crazy but I'm Way more
productive in the figma web app than I
am in the adobe illustrator desktop app
and it's completely free for my graphic
design needs and because it's web-based
I can open up my project on any machine
and all my files will be there
immediately without any effort but aside
from that it's also just a really
well-designed piece of software it's
similar to sketch in the sense that it
gives you all the things that you need
and want and none of the crap that you
don't and it has some superpowers if
you're an app developer for example you
can lock up different events that happen
on the elements and then you can even
export your styles as CSS or as Android
or iOS styles I've been consistently
impressed with figma across the board
and I really feel like I should be
paying them more than zero dollars a
month to be using this thing but there
are times when a full-blown design tool
is more than you actually need so that
brings me to another web app called font
clipper this app is built using angular
and firebase and its sole purpose is to
help you choose fonts for your designs
there are hundreds if not thousands of
free fonts on Google but it's really
tedious to go through and try to figure
out the perfect one for your design
font flipper allows you to bring in your
own graphics and then experiment with
different fonts and what I really like
about it is that it's just a really
focused and simple UI that doesn't
distract you in any way but the coolest
feature is how you actually select the
fonts and it's done with a tinder style
UI where you swipe left for things you
don't like and right for things you do
like and once you decide on a few fonts
that you like you can just go download
them directly from google fonts now
we're going to switch gears and look at
a new Chrome extension called viz bug
this was released earlier this year and
it's a tool that allows you to interact
visually with your website you can see
here we're on fire ship IO and then we
have this toolbar over on the left side
and these pink lions hovering all over
the different dom elements on the site
there's all kinds of different stuff we
can do here and I may do a full tutorial
in the future but basically we can
measure elements we can move things
around change their style and you can do
everything live in the browser without
having to write a single line of CSS
this is extremely powerful because you
can get things to a state that you
actually like and then instead of
rewriting all that CSS you can just copy
and paste it from the inspector and
another thing I really like is that you
can search for a specific type of
element for example if you want to find
all the links on the page we can just
search for them and they'll all be
highlighted in pink the plugin does have
a little bit of a learning
to get used to but once you have that
down it will save you a ton of time now
let's switch gears to a back-end tool
that you can use to debug API is called
insomnia I've worked with a lot of rest
clients over the years and you can use
ones that are integrated directly in vs
code but I always seem to go back to
insomnia whether you're building a REST
API or a graph QL API this app will help
you keep your entire workflow organized
it allows you to save reusable values
that you can go back and use as you
debug your API because you definitely
don't wanna be spending your time
rewriting tedious HTTP requests every
day and on top of that it just has a
beautiful and well laid out UI for
example we might want to create a new
request for the SpaceX graph QL API and
insomnia will automatically do the
introspection so all we have to do is
start typing out our query and we'll get
this awesome intellisense for everything
we type so the power of graph QL
combined with insomnia just gives you an
awesome overall developer experience and
with that we'll move on to the seventh
and final app flare this is another
design tool but one specifically for
creating 2d vector animations it's
similar to figma in the sense that you
can use it to draw graphics but you'll
see down here at the bottom we also have
keyframes to control the motion of the
graphics over time and flare is part of
the open design movement which means you
can see the work of all kinds of other
designers directly on the site and learn
exactly how they built their animations
but a big part of the reason I'm really
excited about flare is that these
graphics can be exported to work in
flutter that means that implementing in
beautiful high-performance animations in
a native mobile app is easier than ever
before I'll create a full tutorial on
this in the future but if you're
building animations in a native app I
can't imagine a better option than flare
I'm gonna go ahead and wrap the list up
there like I said at the beginning of
the video these are all products that I
use personally and that I can vouch for
and another thing I just realized that
wasn't planned is that all these tools
are free and they're also all built with
web technologies and that's a beautiful
thing in my opinion I'd really like to
hear more about the tools that make you
more productive so let me know what
you're using in the comments if this
video helped you please like and
subscribe thanks for watching and I will
talk to you soon wow that's incredible
[Music]